je me sens beaucoup mieux avec un masque
et je pense que tout le monde devrait
faire cela toujours porter un masque
[Musique]
je ne sais pas si les restrictions ont
été supprimés trop tôt
je pense que le relâchement de la
fermeture est un pas vers l'économie
certaines entreprises ont été autorisés
à ouvrir leurs portes
toute cette situation m'a affecté car
j'ai une petite entreprise non loin
d'ici mais je pense qu'il est trop tôt
pour être trop optimistes je me sens
relativement en sécurité
je mets un masque quand je vais dans un
magasin où il ya beaucoup de monde mais
cela n'a pas de sens de le porter à
l'extérieur